The
AACR Annual Meeting is the focal point of the cancer research
community, where attendees gather to share the latest advances in
cancer science and medicine.
With the theme of Precision. Partnership.
Purpose.: Advancing Cancer Science to Save Lives Globally,
the AACR Annual Meeting highlights the work of the best minds in
cancer research from around the world.
Welcome to San Diego.
Please welcome the Chief Executive Officer of the American Association for
Cancer Research, Dr. Margaret Foti.
Thank you. Good morning, everyone.
On behalf of the American Association for Cancer Research, I have the distinct
pleasure of welcoming you to the AACR Annual Meeting
2026 in beautiful San Diego.
Each year, this meeting brings together the global cancer research community
for what is the premier forum for presenting and discussing the
most important breakthroughs in cancer science and medicine.
This year marks the 117th time that the
cancer research community has gathered under the AACR banner to
advance our shared mission to prevent and cure all
cancers.
We are deeply grateful to the 22,500
attendees joining us here in San Diego, as well as the
many virtually from around the world.
Your active participation reflects the extraordinary breadth,
scientific scope, and vitality of global cancer
research.
The AACR Annual Meeting is widely recognized as the most innovative
and influential cancer research meeting in the world.
That distinction has been achieved because of the groundbreaking science
presented, the collaborations forged, and the
collective determination of the individuals gathered here in
person and online.
Together, you represent the global engine of discovery that
is saving more lives and changing the trajectory of cancer for
all populations.
I would like to take this opportunity to thank AACR's officers and
members of the board of directors for their vision and steadfast
leadership in guiding our organization.
I also want to extend my heartfelt thanks to our annual meeting program
chairs, Paul Michiel and Alice Shaw, who have contributed
countless hours to shaping this spectacular
scientific meeting.
Their tireless effort, as well as that of the program committees and
subcommittees, is evident in the stellar
program that has brought us here today.
Preventing and curing all cancers remains one of the greatest scientific and
medical challenges of our time. For
generations, the brightest minds in science and medicine have devoted their
talents to understanding and addressing this complex
disease.
This perseverance has yielded extraordinary progress, as you
know.
From uncovering the molecular foundations of cancer to
pioneering immunotherapies and precision medicines that are transforming
patient care,
the great strides made in cancer research have already benefited
countless patients.
Yet cancer continues to affect millions of individuals and
their families around the world.
That reality compels us to press forward with urgency,
collaboration, and unwavering commitment.
For 119 years, AACR, along with its
dedicated members, have been at the forefront of this quest,
serving as a catalyst for discovery, a convener of the global cancer
research community, and a powerful voice
for scientists, oncologists, other healthcare professionals, and
patient advocates.
A cornerstone of this leadership is AACR's portfolio of
scientific journals, which serves as a critical
platform for disseminating that progress.
And I might add that this year, we received 16,000 submissions of
manuscripts for consideration for publication, the highest number
ever.
This year, we have the pleasure of welcoming several new
editors-in-chief to our journals.
Elizabeth Jaffee and Tony Ribas assume their new roles as
editors-in-chief of Cancer Immunology Research in January,
and their efforts will build on the phenomenal achievements of
Bob Schreiber and Philip Greenberg, whose service to cancer
immunology research over the last 10 years has been truly
exemplary.
At Blood Cancer Discovery, Ross Levine now serves alongside the founding
editors-in-chief, Riccardo Dalla-Favera and Ken Anderson,
bringing his vast expertise to this important journal
that covers research in all aspects of hematologic
malignancies. And at Cancer Discovery, we're happy to
inform you that Matthew Vander Heiden will join as editor-in-chief
alongside Luis Diaz. We want to offer
our profound thanks to Cancer Discovery's outgoing founding
editor, Lou Cantley, a truly titanic presence,
who set the standard of excellence for which Cancer Discovery is
now known. We are really thrilled to have these distinguished leaders
serving in these really critical editorial
roles. To be able to publish your outstanding work is a true
honor.
Their wealth of knowledge and perspectives will uphold and continue
to grow the excellence of our scientific publications program.
I also want to mention that we are proud to mark a new record at this
meeting60 simultaneous publications in AACR
journals, including 23 linked to oral presentations,
underscoring the strength of our journals as partners
in sharing timely, high-impact science at our wonderful
meeting here.
Our impressive portfolio of AACR journals serves a critical role
in disseminating the incredible progress being made by dedicated researchers
like yourselves. But none of this progress is possible
without investment in research and in partnerships.
We are especially pleased to announce the fruits of an enduring and productive
partnership. This year, the Pfizer Kohler Foundation AACR
International Award for Extraordinary Achievement in Cancer
Research will be presented to Doug Lowy and John
Schiller for their groundbreaking research in developing the HPV
vaccine, which as you know, is a revolutionary vaccine that
protects against countless HPV-driven cancers.
AACR was proud to expand its collaborations with a new
joint funding program aimed at identifying high-risk
cancers early. AACR, along with the
Lustgarten Foundation, the Mark Foundation, Breakthrough Cancer,
and the Honorable Tina Brosman Foundation, have teamed up to
invest $12 million in six exciting research projects
focused on pancreatic, ovarian, and esophageal
cancers, as well as cancer predisposition syndromes.
Maximizing the results of cancer research requires a
combined effort across sectors and organizations, and
this year we're very proud to announce the inaugural recipients of
the AACR Torrey Coast Foundation Trans-Pacific Gastro and
Esophageal Cancer Research Partnership,
a grant that is making the launch of a new program
designed to advance cancer research through global
collaboration. These awards support international
team-based science, pairing investigators from the United
States and Asia to address shared challenges in
gastric and esophageal cancer research.
And this partnership reflects AACR's commitment to fostering
cross-border collaboration and accelerating progress globally.
And you may know that 35% of our members are from outside the United
States.
Our 65,014 members, by the way.
We are deeply grateful to the Torrey Coast Foundation for its visionary leadership
and partnership in launching this important global research effort.
We want to thank our partners throughout the pharmaceutical, biotechnology, and
nonprofit sectors, as well as our other generous donors,
for their role in supporting AACR as we expand the scope of our
mission. Industry remains a vital pillar of the
biomedical ecosystem, and we're very, very grateful for their
contributions to accelerating progress against
cancer. At this juncture, I would like to thank the AACR
staff, who through their outstanding work, enable everything
that we do. It has been a tradition to recognize
AACR staff members who have reached milestones in service to our
organization. This year, three individuals
celebrate 25 years at AACR, a testament to their
commitment to our organization and to our shared
cause.
I hope that we will hear a video now.
Okay, I'll introduce Dave Livwell.
First, we would like to recognize Dave Livwell, who serves as
an assistant director
of production for AACR's exceptional scientific
publishing division. When Dave began his AACR
career as senior editor in 2001, AACR's journals
portfolio consisted of just four journals, and the
division was just beginning to implement two technological
innovations that would transform the publishing program
with online publication and online peer review.
Dave assisted in these critical transitions, and he also supported the
launch of six new high-impact journals over the next two
decades of his tenure. As authors of articles in AACR's
journals, you have likely benefited from his expertise, and we're
very grateful to him for his contributions throughout his distinguished
career. Dave is unable to join us here in person in San
Diego, but we are happy to share his video remarks as we celebrate
his outstanding 25 years of service to AACR.
Thanks for recognizing my 25 years here at the AACR.
When I started, there were less than 50 employees, and we were located just
across the street at the Public Ledger Building.
I've accumulated so many great memories since then, and I still
believe in the long-standing mission of the AACR.
I met great colleagues along the way and the best cancer researchers
in the world. I'm grateful to Marge for all her support along the
way and her great leadership. I also thank Mike
Beverage for hiring me so long ago.
Where has the time gone? This company has become one of the
mainstays of my life, and I hope to see you
all in 2051 when I'll be celebrating my 50th
year at the AACR.
Excellent.
Thank you. Congratulations, Dave.
Next, we are pleased to recognize Adam Young, who serves as the Assistant Director
of HR and Benefits Management in the HR department of
AACR. When Adam began his AACR career, the
organization consisted of just 85 staff members, and we've
now grown to 265. The number of
AACR members has more than tripled, obviously, over the last 25
years, and throughout his career, Adam has played a critical role in
the recruitment and retention of the most outstanding staff at
AACR. Please join me in welcoming Adam to the stage to be
recognized for his 25 years of exceptional service to
AACR and the cancer field
Congratulations. You look fabulous.
Thank you. You do too.
Okay. Break a leg.
Good morning, everyone. Standing here today, it's hard to wrap my head around the
fact that it's been 25 years since I first walked through the doors of the
AACR.
A quarter-century is more than just a milestone.
It is a lifetime of shared goals, breakthroughs, and memories.
When I look back to when I first started, the world looked very different, but the
mission of this organization to prevent and cure cancer was just as urgent
then as it is today.
Being a small part of that mission for two and a half decades has been the greatest
honor of my professional life. I want to express my deepest gratitude to Dr.
Foti.
Your visionary leadership and unwavering dedication to the AACR have been a
constant source of inspiration.
Thank you for your trust and for fostering an environment where we can all
contribute to something much larger than ourselves.
It has been the privilege of a lifetime to support your vision and the mission of
the AACR.
To my colleagues across the entire organization, thank you.
It takes a village to support the global cancer research community, and I've been
so lucky to work alongside such brilliant, passionate people.
I'm proud of the work we've done together to support the brilliant minds of this
organization and the members of the AACR.
To those who were here when I started, thank you for showing me the ropes and
laying the foundation.
To my current team, thank you for your energy, your humor, and your dedication
every single day. You make coming to work a joy.
Finally, a very special thank you to my family, my wife, Susan, my three kids, I
adore McKinley, Harrison, and Brynn.
You have been my rock through every long week and every annual meeting season.
I'm here because of your love and support, and I share this milestone with you.
Twenty-five years ago, I came here for a job.
Today, I stand here with a career I'm proud of and a community I truly love.
Thank you all for being part of this incredible journey.
As I look ahead, I'm filled with pride for what we have accomplished and excitement
for what the AACR will achieve next. Thank you.
Thank you, Adam.
You can see how our staff is inspired by your work and our mission, and
I'm just so thrilled about Adam's performance.
And he has helped us hire some fantastic people.
So finally, we are thrilled to honor Mike Stewart, AACR's Chief
Financial Officer and SVP of Finance and Business Administration,
which of course you know is a very important role.
Mike began his distinguished career with AACR in 2001 as
Director of Finance, and since that time, AACR's membership,
programs, and staff have all grown dramatically, and he has
helped our organization manage that growth successfully while
AACR continued to serve its core mission.
During Mike's tenure, AACR's finances have increased steadily,
allowing us to launch new programs of importance to the cancer
field, especially contributions to research grants
that are important to the community.
Over the past 25 years, like with other nonprofit biomedical
organizations, AACR has faced a number of challenges
because of unexpected external factors of which you are all
aware. Because of Mike's sound financial leadership, AACR was
able to overcome these obstacles on our behalf.
And working closely with three different AACR treasurers, Barney
Clarkson, Bill Height, and now Mike Caligiuri, and with the
Finance and Audit Committee, he has been an outstanding steward of
AACR's resources, and we're so grateful to him for his dedication
and stalwart efforts to advance our mission.
Please join me in welcoming Mike to the stage as we celebrate his
25 years of exceptional service to AACR and the cancer field.
Congratulations.
Good morning.
Thank you for the kind words. I sincerely appreciate it.
While 25 years may sound like a long time, it's gone by remarkably
fast. It has truly been an honor and a privilege to work at
AACR and to have the opportunity to collaborate with so many talented
and dedicated people, including the AACR Board of Directors, the Finance
Committee, members, and countless volunteers who support our mission.
To my colleagues at AACR, thank you for the collaboration, the
commitment, the lessons, and the laughter.
I've been fortunate to work alongside individuals who are not only talented and
dedicated, but also generous with their time and knowledge.
I would especially like to thank everyone in the Finance and Business
Administration division. Your dedication, professionalism,
and hard work make my job easy, and I'm truly, truly grateful to work with
such an outstanding team.
I'd also like to extend a special thank you to you, Marge, for your support,
leadership, mentorship, and confidence in me.
I've learned so much during my time working with you, and I continue to be
amazed by your intellect, your passion, and your unwavering
commitment to the cancer research community.
Most importantly, I want to acknowledge my family, my wife, Kathy, and
our children, Kev, Jess, and Dan. Your patience, encouragement,
and understanding, especially during the long hours and demanding travel schedules,
have made this journey possible. This milestone belongs to you as
much as it does to me. I'm often asked why I would want to work for the same
organization for 25 years. And the answer is quite simple.
The mission of the AACR is profoundly important, and I'm fortunate to play even
a small part.
Like many of us here today, cancer has personally touched my life.Through the
loss of my mother, Carrie, to colon cancer, my mother-in-law, Cass, to
T-cell lymphoma, and most recently, my 18-year-old nephew, AJ, to
Rhabdomyosarcoma,
I know firsthand how deeply this disease affects families.
But at the same time, I've witnessed the extraordinary dedication,
compassion, and commitment of the doctors, nurses, researchers,
and countless others working tirelessly to cure cancer and improve patient
lives.
As someone who began his career as a young accountant, I feel incredibly fortunate
to support an organization with such an honorable and meaningful mission.
And since I'm a numbers guy, I thought I'd close by sharing two data points that
highlight the remarkable progress of the cancer research community over the past
25 years.
Between 2000 and 2023, the overall cancer mortality rate declined
by 29%,
and more importantly, the number of cancer survivors living in the United States
has nearly doubled over the past 25 years, increasing from
9.8 million to 18.6 million. These
incredible advances are possible because of the individuals in this room today
and because of all the dedicated people across the cancer research community who
continue this vital work every day.
So thank you again for this recognition and for the privilege of being part of such
an exceptional organization. Enjoy the meeting.
Thank you, Mike.
So you can see how grateful we are to these three individuals who've really
given a major portion of their careers to the AACR,
and they're inspired by you, obviously.
So now it is my distinct pleasure to introduce the president of
AACR, Lillian Siu, with whom I've had the enormous
privilege of working closely over the past year.
Lillian Siu is a longtime member of AACR and a fellow
of the AACR Academy. She's the senior medical oncologist at
Princess Margaret Cancer Centre in Toronto, where she serves as
co-director of the Phase One Clinical Trials program,
co-director of the Robert and Maggie Brason Family Drug Development
Program, clinical lead for the Tumor Immunotherapy
Program, and the BMO Chair in Precision
Cancer Genomics. And of course, we all benefit from her
incredible expertise in all these areas.
She's contributed extensively to the AACR, having previously
served as a member of the board of directors from 2017
to 2020, as a chair of the 2025
AACR Program Committee, and as co-chair of several
AACR scientific conferences. Additionally, she remains an
active member of the AACR International Canada Board of
Directors, and that's an exciting new venture.
Before and during her presidency, despite her significant
workload at Princess Margaret, Lillian has worked very hard
to strengthen our programs and initiatives at AACR,
especially in the areas of clinical research and clinical
trials, translational research, and leadership training of
young investigators, and you'll hear more about that from her.
I want to again thank her for her amazing leadership.
Our organization, its members, will continue to benefit from her
remarkable legacy. Please join me in welcoming the
2025/26 AACR President, Dr. Lillian
Siu.
You're
the...
Thank you.
Good seeing you. Good morning.
Thank you very much, Marge, for your kind introduction.
Serving alongside you for the past year has been an honor and a privilege.
I would like to join Marge in expressing my gratitude to
this year's program chairs, Paul Michiel and Alan Shaw, as well
as the members of the program committee and sub-committees.
None of this would have been possible without your hard work and
extraordinary expertise. Saving lives while
ensuring a high quality of life for cancer patients is central to the
ethos of the AACR, and I'm excited to share the progress
that we have made at the AACR Center for Cancer Clinical Trials.
AACR is launching a first-of-its-kind clinical study, which will
assess the feasibility of using a multi-biomarker
informed treatment approach to spare patients with gastroesophageal
cancer from life-altering surgery.
We're especially grateful for the deep partnerships with
industry, academic institutions, and advocacy
organizations that have made this initiative possible.
We're thrilled that the IND application for GLITZ Clinical Trial has been
approved both by the US FDA and Health Canada,
and the trial will enroll its first patients this year.
Initiatives like this, which are the culmination of decades of
basic and translational research, and a cornerstone of continued
progress against cancer, progress that I'm thrilled to say
remains robust.
The latest data have shown an all-time low in cancer mortality,
down nearly 35% since the peak in the
1990s. Because of your scientific contributions,
we're very proud of three decades of fewer deaths from
cancer and three decades of sustained progress.
The latest edition of the AACR Cancer Progress Report also
gave us welcome news. There are now about 6.6
million more cancer survivors living in the US than there were
when the first AACR Cancer Progress Report was written
15 years ago.
And as the latest report states, FDA approved more than
20 new anticancer therapeutics between July
2024 and June
2025.Any successful campaign
against cancer in all its forms must be ambitious in its
scope. That is why AACR persists in calling attention to
historically underfunded areas of cancer research, including
pediatric cancer. This past year, we published the
inaugural AACR Pediatric Cancer Progress Report.
It is especially devastating when cancer impacts children, and
in launching this report, AACR is committed to providing a
resource that shows just how far cancer research has come in
improving outcomes for children afflicted with cancer
while addressing how much further we need to go.
The theme of our annual meeting this year speaks to the global nature of
cancer research. With more than 65,000
members residing in 143 countries and territories,
more than one-third of whom reside outside of the US,
AACR's reach reflects its dedication to creating and
sustaining a worldwide community of cancer researchers.
Notably, associate members comprise more than half of our membership,
and this year marks the 30th anniversary of the creation of the
Associate Member Council, which serves as an advisory body to
the AACR leadership on issues of concern to the next
generation of cancer researchers.
Therefore, I'm particularly pleased to celebrate the ongoing success of
AACR On Campus events.
Over the past year, AACR organized such events in Taiwan,
Malaysia, and Colombia, where researchers from these regions
participated in workshops designed to disseminate the latest
findings in the cancer field.
I personally had the privilege of representing AACR in Taiwan and can
speak firsthand to the program's success.
AACR On Campus will continue this year when, in August, the program
will meet in Warsaw for researchers from Poland
and Ukraine. And with the opening of the AACR Asia
Pacific office in Singapore this year, we're taking an
important step to further strengthen AACR's global cancer
research leadership, establishing a dynamic hub for
scientific collaborations and discovery across one of the most
rapidly advancing regions in the world.
This effort will deepen our engagement with the Asia Pacific research
community and create new opportunities to connect cancer
investigators, clinicians, and other innovators
across continents in service of our mission.
As part of this expansion, we're also planning the inaugural AACR
Asia Pacific Conference in 2027, which will serve as
a cornerstone for scientific exchange and collaboration across the
region.
All these efforts are essential to fostering a universal
vision for the future of cancer research.
To that end, I'm proud to announce a new AACR
initiative designed to reinforce the cancer research talent
pipeline, the AACR Professional Excellence Program,
or PEP.
Launching this year, PEP is dedicated to developing
a core of new oncology leaders with the skill set to
drive innovation and collaboration across the basic,
translational, clinical, and population science landscape.
We look forward to selecting 20 meritorious early-stage
investigators this year and announcing the inaugural
class at the AACR Annual Meeting in
2027.
AACR has achieved so much over the years, and these achievements are
due to the input and dedication of our members.
As president, I have been very lucky to witness the breadth of the
AACR's extraordinary impact on research, the pace
of progress we enable, the scope of our international
endeavors, and the responsibilities we are humbled to carry on our
shoulders. You are the foundation of this
organization, and it has been an honor to work with you to
make further inroads into our shared mission to prevent
and cure all cancers. Thank you.
And now, to present the recipients of the AACR June L.
Beidler Prize for Cancer Journalism, please welcome
Adjunct Professor of Journalism at Columbia University School of
Journalism, former editor-in-chief of Fortune, and chair of
the Beidler Prize judging panel, Clifton Leaf.
Good morning. I'm delighted to be here today to honor the
recipients of the AACR June L. Beidler Prize for
Cancer Journalism. The AACR established this
prize in 2015 to honor the memory of Dr.
June L. Beidler, a pioneer in cancer research
and former member of the AACR Board of Directors.
Dr. Beidler, whose estate presented the AACR after her
death in 2012 with the largest legacy gift the
organization had ever received, strongly believed that science
communication is critical to the acceleration of
progress, and she was deeply committed to enhancing the
way in which cancer research is communicated to various
audiences, including the public.
The prize raises awareness of the critical role that the media
play in educating the public about cancer and
vital importance of cancer research, and recognizes
outstanding journalist coverage that enhances the
general public's understanding of cancer science and medicine.
There is nothing about cancer, the science,
the treatmentThe day-to-day experience of
patients that isn't steeped in complexity.
And these Beidler winners brought clarity and understanding to
every question they explored. That is what great
reporters do.
And now, the 2026 recipients of the AACR
Gene L. Beidler Prize for Cancer Journalism.
Laurie Abraham is a freelance journalist and editor recognized
in the magazine category for her comprehensive look into current
research and treatment in colorectal cancer.
Her story took readers through her own diagnosis and treatment,
explaining the natural aversion to talking about a cancer that is
often considered shameful, and translating highly
technical medical information into understandable language for
a lay audience.
Carolyn Johnson is a journalist at "The Washington Post,"
recognized in the newspaper category for a timely article
that merged two intersecting narratives, a look into
promising new research in using tumor-infiltrating lymphocyte
therapy on solid tumors, and the story of a
patient who enrolled in an NIH clinical trial testing TIL
therapy, only to face uncertainty when key members
of the trial team were laid off due to reduction in force
announcements for the NIH.
Her work highlighted how politics can impede scientific
progress and the many individuals who are directly affected
by these decisions.
Robert Langreth, Tanaz Majani, and Anna Edney
are journalists at Bloomberg News.
They are recognized in the online multimedia category for a
three-part series on what they called cancer capitalism, in
which the drive for profit can harm patients.
The series analyzed the data behind high-cost cancer pharmaceuticals,
examined a medical device implanted in breast cancer patients that failed to
dissolve as intended, and explored how lower doses of
$200,000 drugs may help hundreds of thousands of
people around the world. Unfortunately, Tanaz and Anna are
unable to join us today.
Jess Burns and Brooke Herbert are journalists with Oregon Public
Broadcasting. They are recognized in the television,
podcast, and radio category for a video report on how
researchers in Oregon aim to slow down cancer by
remotely cooking tumors. This creative report took
a lighthearted approach to explaining innovative scientific research,
using graphics and props to humanize the scientific process
and make complex concepts understandable while
showcasing an emerging nanotechnology-based approach
in slowing tumor growth.
Kristen Severance and Dwayne Myers are reporters at
WRAL in Raleigh, North Carolina.
They are also recognized in the television, radio, podcast category
for a compelling exploration of the growing prevalence of cancer
diagnoses among younger adults.
Through powerful personal stories, their piece effectively
educated viewers about how cancer has increasingly affected
populations that have not traditionally been seen at high risk,
challenging long-held assumptions about age and
cancer and deepening public awareness of an important and
evolving cancer trend. Please join me in congratulating
this year's prize recipients.
Please welcome the President of the AACR Academy and Fellow,
Dr. Elaine V. Fuchs.
Welcome, everyone.
So the AACR Academy, founded in
2013, recognizes exceptional
scientists whose groundbreaking contributions have
driven meaningful advances in cancer research.
Now, with nearly 400 elected members,
the fellows of the AACR Academy represent a global
community of experts and thought leaders who serve
as a vital force to offer valuable insights and
guidance to the AACR leadership on critical and
emerging issues.
Our goal is to work collectively with the AACR to
fulfill its bold mission of preventing and curing all
cancers.
This year, we proudly welcome 24
pioneers in cancer science and medicine as newly
elected fellows of the AACR Academy.
Nineteen of these individuals are with us today, joined
by four individuals from last year's elected class of
AACR fellows.
Each elected individual has been selected through a highly
competitive, peer-driven review process led by the
fellows of the AA Academy leadership committees and
ratified by the AACR's leadership.
This rigorous evaluation includes a comprehensive
review of each nominee's contributions to cancer
research and related scientific disciplines.
We are honored to celebrate the remarkable achievements
of these distinguished individuals to recognize the profound
impact that their work has had in advancing progress
against cancer.
When I call your namePlease join me on stage to be
recognized for your groundbreaking scientific
accomplishments and your election as a fellow of the
AACR Academy.
From the 2025 class of fellows,
Dr. Elaine S. Jaffe
Dr.
John Kurian
Dr. Ari Melnick
and Dr. Leonard Zon.
And from the 2026 class of fellows of the
AACR Academy,
Dr. Cory Abate Shen,
Dr. Alberto
Bardelli,
Dr.
Benjamin Cravatt,
Dr. Christina Curtis
...
Your arms are going to get tired here.
Dr. Julio Dreata
Dr. Louis Lemierre
Dr. Anthony G. Letai
Dr.
Ross L. Levine
Dr. William G. Nelson
Dr. Gary Nolan
Dr. Kenneth Offit
Dr. Pamela Ohashi
Dr. Charles Roberts
Dr. Alice Shaw
Dr. Yosef Shiloh
Dr. Kimberly Stegmeyer
Dr. Matthew Vander Heiden
Dr. Jennifer Wargo
and Dr. Lawrence Vitogel.
So,
please join me in applauding these recently elected
fellows of the AACR Academy.
Well-deserved honors.
So as we conclude this recognition of our newly elected
fellows, we're reminded that the achievements of the
Academy as a whole reflect not only the
excellence in past and current discoveries, but also
a commitment to shaping the future of cancer
research.
So today, I'm very proud to announce the launch of a
new fundraising campaign that is spearheaded
by the Academy and endorsed by the AACR
leadership.
This is to establish a dedicated funding mechanism that
will ensure the future generations of the best and brightest
scientists in cancer research. The funds that we are
raising will support outstanding post-doctoral and
clinical research fellows in their final year of training
before they transition to independent careers in cancer
research.
While our Academy fellows have ignited the flame of this
initiative, we invite all of you to
reflect upon your own career, and then give back to your
community by helping to carry the philanthropic torch
that will ensure sustained support of young cancer
researchers as they strive to move up through the ranks
during this critical transition period.
So please visit the AACR website or the
AACR Central that's located in the sales pavilion to learn
how you might be able to support this important new initiative.
I know that you will be glad that you gave back for
what you've been given, and please help with regards to
really the future of our great young
scientists.
Well, as the video demonstrates, this
past year has been a very difficult one in that we mourn the loss of so
many distinguished members of the cancer research community,
including the following leaders in the field.
Dr. Edward Chu, an inspiring Chinese American leader
and role model. Dr. Chu was the director of the Montefiore
Einstein Comprehensive Cancer Center since 2020.
And under his leadership,
he was in the cancer field, he really earned his first
NCI comprehensive status as cancer center
director.
As a 38-year member, Dr. Chu
also served with distinction on the editorial boards of "Cancer
Research" and "Clinical Cancer Research."
Dr. Pelayo Correa, a fellow of the AACR
Academy, whose work really defined the histological stages of the
development of gastric cancer, fundamentally advanced our
understanding of the pathology,
epidemiology, and prevention of the disease.
An AACR member since 1980, Dr. Correa was the founding
editor-in-chief of the AACR journal,
"Cancer Epidemiology Biomarkers & Prevention"
from 1991 to 1997.
Dr. Thomas W. Kensler, a trailblazer in cancer
prevention, who was among the first to conduct Westernized human
clinical trials in China. An AACR member
since 1979, Dr. Kensler provided
valued service on several committees of the AACR, including
the AACR Program Committee and the Steering Committee of the AACR
Cancer Progress Report, and he also served as senior
editor of the AACR journal, "Cancer Prevention Research."
And Dr. David Baltimore, an inaugural fellow of the AACR
Academy, who shared the Nobel Prize in Physiology or Medicine
in 1975 for elucidating how tumor
viruses interact with the genetic material of the cell.
Beyond the laboratory, Dr. Baltimore was a leading advocate
for federal investment in AIDS research, serving as the chair
of the NIH AIDS Vaccine Research Committee from
1996 to 2002.
And Dr. J. Michael Bishop, an inaugural fellow of the AACR
Academy, who shared the Nobel Prize in Physiology or Medicine in
for his discovery of the cellular origin of retroviral oncogenes.
The discovery that cancer could be caused by the
malfunction of normal genes revolutionized the understanding of
tumorigenesis
and really greatly expanded the scope of associated scientific
areas such as cancer detection and drug discovery and
development. And Dr. James D. Watson, an
inaugural fellow of the AACR Academy, who shared the Nobel Prize in
Physiology or Medicine in 1962 for the discovery
of the double helix structure of DNA. Dr.
Watson also led the trailblazing Human Genome Project at
NIA, which I'm sure you're aware of, from 1990 to
1992. And in 2007, he really
became the second person to publish his own fully
sequenced
genome online. And my dear friend and mentor,
Dr. Byard D. Clarkson,
an inaugural fellow of the AACR Academy, who pioneered the
development of targeted therapies aimed at cancer stem cells.
Barney was an AACR member for 63 years, and
his dedication to AACR is evidenced by the fact that he is the only
person to have ever held four major AACR leadership
positions at AACR: President, Treasurer,
Member of the Board of Directors, and President and Founding Chair of the
Board of Trustees of the AACR Foundation.
And of course, I'm indebted to him because he appointed me many years ago.
So please join me in honoring all these remarkable scientists and all
of the outstanding AACR members we have lost over
the past year with a moment of silence.
Thank you.
And now it is my pleasure to present the 2026
AACR Outstanding Achievement Award for Service to Cancer Science and
Medicine to Dr. David R. Parkinson.
Dr. Parkinson serves as Principal, Drug Discovery, at the Ellison
Medical Institute. He's being honored for extraordinary leadership
in advancing life-saving cancer therapeutics, strengthening national
cancer research and regulatory initiatives, spearheading
biopharmaceutical innovations that have transformed
patient care, and providing vital scientific and
fiduciary oversight to AACR. Dr. Parkinson
is a leader in the biopharmaceutical and healthcare industries,
with extensive experience in major scientific, clinical,
development, regulatory, business, and management roles.
Early in his career, he served as Chief of the Investigational
Drug Branch at the NCI.His career
trajectory has been spectacular.
Later, he led oncology clinical development at Novartis,
Amgen, and Biogen Idec. He served in major
leadership roles at Zynjia
Incorporated, Nodality, and most recently, Esso
Pharmaceuticals before joining the Ellison Medical
Institute.
During his career, Dr. Parkinson has overseen the successful
clinical development of numerous cancer therapeutics, including
Gleevec, Xometa, Femara, and Vectibix.
He also has served as chair of the FDA's Biologics
Advisory Committee, as well as co-chair of
the Cancer Steering Committee at the foundation of the NIH
Biomarkers Consortium. He became a member
in 1989, and he has served the organization with
distinction in a wide range of roles.
He served on the board of directors from 2006 to 2009 as
chair of the finance committee for 15 years, starting in
2001. More recently, he has served as a member of the AACR
Oncology Development Fund,
actually since 2022, and he's helping us raise
new funds for research grants. In addition, he has provided
invaluable stewardship as the chair of the AACR
Project Genie EAB. He served in that
capacity since its launch in 2015, contributing really
to the remarkable growth of what is now the world's largest public registry of
real-world clinical genomic cancer data.
Dr. Parkinson is a trusted expert in cancer drug discovery,
whose contributions have led to the development of several life-saving
therapeutics. We are very grateful to him for his dedication to
AACR over these many years, and we are proud to honor him
today. Please join me in welcoming to the stage Dr.
David Parkinson.
Well,
thank you and good morning. I'm David Parkinson, as you just heard.
This is a great honor, and I'm very grateful to the ACR Board of
Directors for this award. It was completely unexpected,
and I'm delighted to receive it, honored to receive it.
It's
caused me to reflect on the activities which I've pursued, which
are numerous, as you've heard,
beyond my various direct professional obligations.
And for example, it took me back to an interview I experienced much
earlier in my career. I was asked to look at a job at a
Boston biotech company, which has now long since disappeared, and
asked to interview for a position which I could never figure out exactly what it
was.
So I didn't take whatever that job would've been.
But in the interview, I was sitting across from a human resources person
who was looking at my CV and looked at me and said,
"My," she said, "You seem to have done a lot of things." And when an
HR person says that to you, that's not a positive comment.
And so I leaned forward,
and I said to her, "You don't understand me.
I've only ever done one thing, and that's try to make cancer
treatment better for patients.
But I have done it from a lot of perspectives." And trust me, that was probably 20
years ago. There's a few more perspectives since then.
But after that, she and I had a civil conversation because I think she had a better
sense of who I was.
And that's the point I'd like to make here this morning.
To me, and I would suggest to many of you, particularly those of
you who are early in your careers,
I think it's important to define
who you are, what you're about,
what you want to achieve in your career,
what you're willing to accept along the way, and what you're not willing
to accept, which sometimes is difficult.
It gives some meaning to your career and a basis to help in the inevitable
decisions and choices that we all face over the years.
So along the way, I've been lucky enough to have a strongly supportive family.
So sincere appreciation to my wife,
my daughter, and my son, James, who is out here somewhere in the
crowd this morning,
and now understands what kind of a meeting I always disappeared to once a
year. Many thanks also to those with whom I've had the opportunity
to work with in many spheres.
In policy recommendations to the Institute of Medicine, in the
diagnostic work we did at the NIH Biomarkers Consortium,
fantastic interactions over the years in various capacities with the
FDA, various international organizations.
I still sit on the board of the Multiple Myeloma Research Foundation, their
investment group. And I've helped in the financial and overall
management of large cancer organizations, such as AACR and the Ontario
Institute of Cancer Research, because I try not to forget my
Canadian origins.
So, particular thanks, though, to the AACR.
I've put a lot of time into the AACR because it's
an organization worth putting a lot of time into.
I've either been on or reported to boards of directors in various capacities
over the years.
I've also had the privilege of working with a fantastic group at Project
Genie and
the external advisory board participantsSo, working in all these
spheres has been the greatest privilege in the world.
It's introduced me to the best people in the biomedical research
world, and I have benefited from those interactions. I have learned.
So thank you again for this wonderful award.
AACR is a great organization. It's been both a pleasure and a
privilege to work with it,
to see it grow and develop over the years.
I intend to continue to help as best I can in that growth and
development, and I would encourage all of you to do the same.
So thank you very much.
Please welcome the chair of the AACR Margaret Foti Award for
Leadership and Extraordinary Achievements in Cancer Research Committee, Dr.
William Kim.
Good morning. It is my great pleasure to present the
2026 AACR Margaret Foti Award for
Leadership and Extraordinary Achievements in Cancer Research.
This award was established at the time of AACR's centennial
anniversary in 2007, in honor of AACR's
remarkable CEO, Dr. Marge Foti, for her exemplary leadership
and her amazing dedication to our mission, the conquest of cancer
through research, communication, collaborations,
education and training, fundraising for cancer research,
and science policy.
The award recognizes a true champion of cancer research, whose
leadership and extraordinary achievements have had a major impact on the
field, and who embodies the sustained commitment of Dr.
Foti to the prevention and cure of all cancers.
Today, we honor a physician scientist whose work has helped redefine
cancer treatment and whose leadership has shaped the direction of modern
oncology. Our honoree for the 2026
AACR Margaret Foti Award for Leadership and Extraordinary Achievements
in Cancer Research is Dr. Anthony Ribas of the
University of California, Los Angeles.
Dr. Ribas is internationally recognized for his pioneering
contributions to cancer immunotherapy, particularly in melanoma.
His leadership in the clinical development of immune checkpoint inhibitors,
including pembrolizumab, helped establish a new standard of
care and extend the impact of immunotherapy across many
cancer types. Beyond these advances, Dr.
Ribas has played a central role in defining how we understand response
and resistance to immunotherapy.
Through studies of tumor and immune interactions, his work has
provided critical insights that continue to guide the development of
next-generation therapies. He's also contributed to the
advancement of innovative treatment strategies, including targeted
combinations and cell-based therapies, and has been instrumental in
building a collaborative and forward-looking research community.
In addition to his scientific accomplishments, Dr.
Ribas has provided outstanding leadership to the field, including his
service as director of the Tumor Immunology Program at the Janssen
Comprehensive Cancer Center, and director of the Parker
Institute for Cancer Immunotherapy at UCLA.
He also previously served as chair of the Melanoma Committee for the Southwest
Oncology Group, and as president of the American Association for
Cancer Research. The impact of Dr.
Ribas' work is incredibly profound.
His leadership in the development of immunotherapies, particularly pembrolizumab,
has driven a paradigm shift in the treatment of melanoma and other cancers,
improving and extending the lives of countless patients worldwide.
And I've known Dr. Ribas now for more than 15 years, and he's incredibly
deserving of this award. And I would like to welcome, first though, Dr.
Foti to the stage to present the award that bears her
name.
Please join me-- Oh.
Please join me in welcoming to the stage the 2026
recipient of the AACR Marge Foti Award for Leadership and
Extraordinary Achievement in Cancer Research, Dr. Anthony Ribas.
Congratulations.
Thank you very much, William, for the kind introduction and for all
of, uh, uh, the society. Thank you very much for this wonderful honor,
made particularly meaningful since it bears the name of Dr.
Marge Foti. I have the privilege of knowing and
working closely with Marge for 15 years.
And for very few who don't know this already, Marge is the most
extraordinary leader our field has ever known.
She has guided our society to unprecedented success
through an incredible journal to where we stand today, with the
AACR being the oldest, largest, and most respected cancer
society in the world. Thank you, Marge.
I owe this honor to many extraordinary people who have guided my career at
UCLA and beyond. I learned from my mentor, Jim Economou,
that the real goal is not to write a paper, but to generate the
knowledge to write one.The goal is understanding new
science that helps patients, and the results are the papers and
grants.
He also taught me cancer immunology and gene therapy at the time where most
people thought they had no chance of treating cancer.
My clinical mentor, John Glaspy, was fearless, so much that he would
treat melanoma when there were no treatments.
He passed the melanoma clinic to me when we started making breakthroughs in this
field.
I have learned so much from Owen Witte at UCLA, and David Baltimore at
Caltech. David, we miss you so much.
I was not a trainee of either of them, but both of them took
so much care during all my career to guide me to reach levels of
scientific excellence that I saw in them, and I thought I was
not able to achieve myself.
I have had outstanding collaborations that have gone on for
years, working with melanoma with Roger Lo and Tom Graeber, in
immunotherapy and nanotechnology with Kaius Radwan and Jim Heath, in
PET imaging with Mike Phelps, Harvey Korsman, and Ana Wu, and many others.
And external collaborations, such as with Alex Marson in
CRISPR gene editing of T cells, and with Chris Garcia on a series of
artificial cytokine receptors.
With my colleagues at the Melanoma Committee of the US Cooperative Group SWOG,
we conducted a series of clinical trials that have changed the standard of care
of patients with melanoma.
I have been blessed with extraordinary trainees who came to my lab.
In many instances, I learned more from them than I think they ever
learned from me. I am so proud to see them
advance in their careers. And finally,
I'm going to thank the inspiration of my father, who was an oncologist, and always
told me, "The most important is to understand why things happen."
And to the unwavering support of my family and friends that make life a
joy. Thank you very much to all.
Please thank the chair of the AACR Award for Lifetime Achievement in
Cancer Research Committee, Dr. David G. Kirsch.
Good morning. I'm David Kirsch, a senior
scientist at University Health Network's Princess Margaret Cancer Center.
It is my great privilege to present this year's AACR Award for
Lifetime Achievement in Cancer Research.
The AACR established this prestigious award in 2004 to
honor individuals who have made significant and fundamental contributions to
cancer research, have had a lasting impact on the field, and have
demonstrated a lifetime commitment to progress against cancer.
Today, we recognize a scientist whose discoveries have transformed both our
understanding of cancer and the way it is treated.
This year's recipient is Dr. James P.
Allison of the University of Texas MD Anderson Cancer
Center. Dr. Allison's work established a new paradigm in
oncology, that the immune system can be harnessed to eliminate
cancer. His discovery that CTLA-4 functions as a
key inhibitory checkpoint, and that blocking this pathway can
unleash antitumor immunity, laid the foundation for immune checkpoint
blockade therapy, a term he helped define.
This insight led to the development of ipilimumab, the first immune
checkpoint inhibitor to demonstrate a survival benefit in patients with
metastatic melanoma, and opened the door to an entirely new class of
therapies that are now used across many cancer types.
Today, these approaches have provided durable benefit to hundreds of
thousands of patients worldwide, and continue to shape the future of cancer
treatment. For these groundbreaking contributions, Dr.
Allison received the Nobel Prize in Physiology or Medicine in
2018. The impact of his work is profound, not
only in scientific discovery, but in the lives of patients who are living
longer because of these advances.
Please join me in welcoming to the stage, the 2026 recipient
of the AACR Award for Lifetime Achievement in Cancer Research, Dr.
James Allison.
Good morning, AACR.
How's everybody doing out there? I thought I'd wake everybody up for a moment.
Anyway, I want to thank the AACR for this extraordinary honor.
To receive this Lifetime Achievement Award is deeply meaningful to me, not
just as recognition of the career of a single person,
but as a celebration of a collective journey shared by so many
remarkable collaborators, mentors, and trainees who have
embraced the vision of immunotherapy as a curative approach to
cancer.
Science has never been a solo endeavor, and I stand here because of many
individuals who ask bold questions, challenged assumptions,
and work tirelessly in support, in pursuit of answers.
The concept of using the immune system to treat cancer is, of course, not new, but
it's been around for over a century.
But after many false starts and failed trials, by the
1980s, the field was essentially ignored by the mainstream.
I don't blame the skeptics for their skepticism, but I greatly
admire the pioneering scientists who kept the flame alive despite the doubt.
I was fortunate enough to have many of the hardcore, including
Bob Shiver, Phil Greenberg, Nina Bhardwaj, Lewis Lanier,
and Lloyd Old, among the many friends and mentors along the
way.When I began studying T cells in the '70s,
I was driven by curiosity and the conviction that if we were to learn
how to use the immune system to treat cancer, we first had to
understand how it worked at the most fundamental level.
And we didn't know where those questions were going to lead.
But it's the nature of discovery science.
You follow the biology, you test the ideas, you reject the wrong
ones, and sometimes, if you're fortunate, you discover something that
can change lives.
The notion of immune checkpoint blockade was built on decades of basic research
by many dedicated students in my lab, and I'm particularly
grateful to Brad McIntyre, Jane Gross, Fiona Harding, Max Krummel,
the late Cynthia Chambers, Andrea Van Elsas, Sergio
Quezada, and others involved in the early studies.
To Alan Korman and Niels Lonberg for creating
MDX-010, to the BMS team and clinical colleagues,
including Glenn Dranoff, Rachel Humphrey, Jedd Wolchok, and Pam
Sharma, who helped get ipilimumab into the clinic and carry it over
the finish line to FDA approval. And importantly, to
Pam Sharma, who wrote the first
ipilimumab trial, and also designed the first neoadjuvant
trial, and also established a program to study immune responses in
patients at MD Anderson. It's my privilege to
work with you every day. You're my partner in science and the love of
my life.
I'm also grateful to the patients and their families who enroll in
clinical trials without expectation of direct benefit.
Your courage and trust continue to inspire us to push forward.
But today, immunotherapy is the cornerstone of cancer treatment,
offering help and very often cures to patients who once
had very few options. But this progress is only the
beginning. Much remains unknown.
Too many patients still do not benefit from available therapies.
The complexity of biology continues to challenge us in ways that
demand deeper thinking, better tools, and sustained
commitment. And that brings me to something I care deeply about.
Scientific progress depends upon long-term investment in people,
in ideas, and in the freedom to explore the unknown.
Breakthroughs don't happen overnight, and they rarely
follow predictable paths. They arise from supporting bold,
sometimes unconventional ideas, and from trusting scientists to
pursue questions whose answers are not immediately obvious.
At a time when research environments are under pressure from many
directions, we must reaffirm our commitment to science,
not only as a profession, but also as a shared and
human endeavor to improve lives worldwide.
We must continue to invest in our young scientists, foster
collaborations across disciplines, and ensure that
innovation can thrive. I've been incredibly fortunate to
be part of this field and to work along so many brilliant people
and dedicated individuals. As founding director of the James
Allison Institute at MD Anderson Cancer Center, and with
Pam Sharma leading the scientific efforts, we remain committed to bringing
together diverse expertise to expand the reach of
immunotherapy and to find new ways to help patients.
It's my firm belief that active engagement of the patient's immune
system will be a critical part of any curative
combinations in the future. Thank you again to the
AACR for this honor. I accept it with gratitude,
humility, and a renewed commitment to the work ahead.
This won't be the last you see of me, because in the end, our goal is simple
and shared by all of us: to bring better treatments and ultimately cures
to every patient who needs them. Thank you very much.
Thank you, Dr. Allison. This is exciting to hear your remarks.
We greatly appreciate your being here and all you've done for the field.
So you all have heard from our president and myself
about what AACR has accomplished during the past year.
As we look to the future, I'm really excited to announce that we
have been laying the groundwork for even greater things to come.
Looking ahead, AACR continues to lead the way in expanding the
frontiers of cancer research, which is achieved through thoughtful
planning to address emerging scientific areas of interest that
are critical to our mission. And as you know, the rapid
rise of AI as a powerful tool in cancer research
has presented us with a responsibility to organize the vital
forums necessary to take the fullest advantage of its
potential.
From publications to presentations at this meeting and other venues,
AACR is facilitating the rapid dissemination of the latest advances
in AI and its role in all areas of cancer research and
patient care.
Similarly, AACR has been galvanizing progress in the rapidly
evolving field of cancer vaccines.
At the second successful AACR Immuno-Oncology Conference hosted
earlier this year, thanks to the vision of Dr.
Ribas, scientists from all specialties
have come together to share their perspectives on how cancer vaccines
can be made to deliver their maximum potential for
cancer patients. And at the first ever Cancer
Vaccine Think Tank, AACR partnered with the Cancer Vaccine
Coalition to unite thought leaders in this field to accelerate
advances and transform cancer care.
AACR also enthusiastically continues to serve on the Cancer
Vaccine Advisory Committee, a new initiative
spearheaded by the Foundation for the NIH, with the aim of
accelerating progress and supporting the development of these promising
new therapies.Harnessing new technologies
like AI and vaccines is really vital to advances in the
cancer outcomes that we continue to make.
But even as cancer mortality trends downward, an
alarming new challenge has emerged, the recent and ongoing rise
in early-onset cancers.
AACR has moved swiftly to make this issue a priority,
and we have dedicated resources to ensure that scientists can
understand and work hard to take bold action against this
looming threat. The horizon of possibilities is
ever-changing, and as new opportunities to counter
cancer come to the fore, we really rely
upon the wisdom and sage counsel of our members to
navigate toward a more promising future.
Thus, AACR has formed a scientific advisory council
comprised of about 50 luminary experts and chaired by our
Chief Scientific Advisor, Bill Hite.
As we prepare AACR for the future, I'm also very excited to
announce our commitment to our Vision
2032 strategic plan under the visionary leadership of
Anne Barker, which will define a path for us to follow as we
move forward to our 125th
anniversary.
This strategic plan will be bold, mission-driven, and instrumental in
shaping AACR's efforts to address the priorities of our
field. And I want you to know that we will be really sending around
surveys to you to really get your perspective as well from our broader
community of this large membership we have of
65,000 individuals. So I'd like to thank the
Strategic Planning Committee and the AACR Scientific
Advisory Council for their vital contributions to this plan.
Of course, addressing the challenges of tomorrow in
cancer incident mortality really requires the ingenuity of
a scientific workforce that rises to the occasion.
I am thrilled that AACR is investing a portion of the
generous gift from Pfizer
to launch the Trailblazer Cancer Research Grants Program, a funding
mechanism that supports innovative scientists who, through their
paradigm-shifting work, will help define the
future of cancer research. The 15 awards,
valued at $1 million each, will equip early-stage and
mid-career investigators with the resources that they need to
execute novel, highly creative projects that will
revolutionize our understanding of cancer
biology. They will drive groundbreaking translational
science and improve patient outcomes.
We are extremely grateful to Pfizer for its impactful gift
in support of AACR's mission to defeat cancer in all of its
forms and of our sustaining-- and it will be helping us
sustain innovation in cancer research.
This donation will further advance cutting-edge science and
catapult the development of life-saving discoveries
against cancer.
At the heart of all these efforts are the individuals whose lives are touched
by cancer. It is with this consideration for the patient
experience that AACR has launched a new initiative on the
healthcare front. This year, in collaboration with the Oncology Nursing
Society and its foundation, we are proud to welcome a
select group of oncology nurse scholars to the AACR Annual
Meeting, whose contributions are critical to translating scientific
discovery into meaningful patient impact.
Oncology nurse scholars will engage closely with our leaders in
cancer research through a curated experience that fosters
meaningful collaboration and ensures that patient care remains
closely aligned with evolving scientific progress.
This program reflects AACR's ongoing commitment to
accelerating discovery, enhancing clinical translation, and
improving patient outcomes in collaboration with
these wonderful individuals. We also wish to
recognize another important segment of the cancer community, our patient
advocates, who are a vital conduit between researchers and
patients whose lives are improved and cured through
cutting-edge therapies. The patient advocates who are present at this
meeting embody extraordinary courage and
generosity of spirit, and we thank them for serving as the
voice of our patients.
Now, it is my great honor to introduce this year's
recipient of the AACR Distinguished Patient Advocacy
and Engagement Award, Jill Feldman.
Jill's journey as an advocate is rooted in profound personal
loss and extraordinary resilience.
By the age of 20, she had lost her father, both grandparents, her
mother, and a close aunt to lung cancer.
These experiences could have defined her by grief, but
instead, they ignited a lifelong commitment to
changing the future of this disease.
Jill channeled that commitment into action, becoming a leader in the
lung cancer community and serving as past president of the LUNGevity
Foundation, the first US nonprofit dedicated exclusively
to lung cancer research. Her
advocacy took on even deeper meaning in 2009 when,
at just 39 years old and the mother of four children, Jill
herself was diagnosed with EGFR-positive lung cancer.
From that moment forward, Jill has embodied what it means to be a patient
advocate
and a very passionate one. She has worked tirelessly to
ensure that the patient voice is not only heard but embedded in
every stage of research and care.
In 2017, she co-founded EGFRresisters,
a patient-driven communityThat has already funded
more than $1 million in research and is accelerating progress for
individuals living with EGFR-mutated lung
cancer. Importantly,
Jill has been a dedicated member of the AACR community, serving
on the 2025 AACR Annual Meeting Program
Committee, mentoring advocates through the AACR Scientist
Survivor Program, and really contributing her voice to
critical conversations about survivorship and patient-centered
research.
Please join me in honoring a truly remarkable and
inspiring patient advocate and community leader,
Jill Feldman.
Wow. Thank you. It's truly an honor, and it's truly an honor to share this
stage with Dr. Ellisson, who has
transformed cancer therapy, and hopefully as
advocates, we can do some transformation
ourselves. But it's hard to put into
words what this honor means to me. To be recognized
by AACR in this way is deeply meaningful,
especially because I am alive because of
cancer research and because of people like all of
you who have devoted your lives to advancing it.
After losing my dad and two grandparents to lung cancer when I
was 13, and then my mom and my aunt when I was in my
20s, I was desperate to find a way to
confront a disease that devastated my family.
But back in 2000, it was a different lung cancer
world. There were very few treatment options, little
funding, and no awareness, and really no
community for patients and families.
Thankfully, the first organization in the country dedicated to lung
cancer research was founded in my community in
2001, and I got involved shortly after it
began.
At the time, lung cancer was considered the invisible
disease. Raising awareness and funds for
research, it was incredibly difficult.
But I did everything I could to educate myself and be an
advocate, and then in
2009, at 39 years old, with
four young children, I was diagnosed with lung
cancer, the same disease I watched take both my parents.
And sadly, there still wasn't much research to convince me that
my path would be different than my parents'.
And knowing the fear my children were living with
made research something so much more than
hope. It became a
lifeline. The funny thing is that
science was my worst subject in school.
Truly, my worst subject.
So if you had told me that I would spend so much of my life in research
meetings, scientific conferences, grant reviews,
and conversations about study designs and endpoints and
clinical benefit, I would have laughed and
not believed it.
But I did learn that I didn't need to be a
scientist to contribute something important.
The expertise that I brought, as all of us
advocates do, is the lived experience.
What it means to live with uncertainty, to
weigh options and trade-offs, and to manage
treatment, family, work, while trying to
stay alive.
And that's important because survival curves and
hazard ratios are only part of the
story.
Science can only tell us the what. What a
drug is or what a dataset shows.
But data struggles with context.
And progress isn't just about extending life.
It's also about understanding how people live,
what they endure, and whether the research that we
celebrate is helping them live well, not
just longer.
Advocates bring that context. That's what we
do. And for research to be both scientifically
rigorous and meaningful, the people
expected to live with the outcome belong in the
room to help shape what is asked, what is
measured, and what is prioritized.
And that is the difference between measurable
progress and meaningful progress.
But we should celebrate all progress. It is really important.
I think my family history does illustrate that.
My dad died at 41 years old, just three months
after he was diagnosed with lung cancer and a few weeks
before I graduated eighth grade.
My mom died at 54, six months after she was
diagnosed, and a few months before my daughter was born.
But thanks to advances in research and treatment, I
have lived 17 years.
Thank
youThank
you.
So those 17 years, I have seen all four of my
kids graduate eighth grade and high school, and
almost college.
But research didn't just extend my life.
It gave me years, those years that were filled with
raising my kids, family trips,
graduations, college drop-offs,
and a lot of advocacy. A lot of
advocacy.
So I've been fortunate to benefit from research, but at the same time,
I think of those who didn't have the chance to benefit from
the progress that we celebrate today, and their memory
is part of what keeps me doing this work.
I also want to recognize that this award is not mine
alone. I didn't get here alone. It reflects the work of
so many advocates who continue to push for better
research, better care, and a deeper
understanding of what it means to live with cancer.
And none of this is possible without the
extraordinary community of scientists,
clinicians, organizations, and companies
who have been willing to listen, to value
patient input, and to recognize
that the lived experience is expertise
and holds equal weight.
So thank you again to AACR for recognizing
that patient advocacy and engagement are essential to
research. I am deeply grateful for this
honor and for all those I have
met, I have learned from, and worked
alongside all these years. Their wisdom and
guidance have helped shape who
I am as an advocate today.
For patients and families, the true value of
research is hope. Hope to live longer and hope to live
better. Thank you all for your tireless
efforts and for giving us that hope.
Thank you.
It is now my honor to introduce a leader whose scientific insight and
dedication to patients reflect the very best of our cancer
research community. Dr. Anthony Letai was
sworn in as the 18th director of the National Cancer Institute
last September.
He brings to this role more than two decades of distinguished service at
Dana-Farber Cancer Institute and Harvard Medical School, where he
established himself as one of the foremost physician
scientists working to understand how cancer cells survive and
how those vulnerabilities can be targeted to improve treatment.
Dr. Letai is widely recognized for his pioneering research
on cancer cell death pathways and for advancing
approaches that are now standard treatment for patients with
leukemia. He has long championed innovation,
collaboration, and scientific rigor, and he is deeply
committed to ensuring that laboratory discoveries
translate into meaningful progress for our patients.
Those qualities are exactly what this moment demands.
Decades of sustained bipartisan investment in the NIH and
NCI have driven extraordinary progress.
The US cancer death rate has declined by 34%
since 1991. Sustaining and accelerating that
progress is the defining challenge ahead, and we are
grateful for the steady, science-driven leadership Dr.
Letai is currently bringing to that work.
Please join me in welcoming the director of the National Cancer
Institute, Dr. Anthony Letai.
Good morning.
It's a true pleasure to be here and a real honor to help
open this year's AACR annual meeting.
That was a beautiful tribute to Jill Feldman, and I think a good reminder
of why we are all here today.
Looking out at this room,
it's hard not to be struck by the depth of experience and commitment that's
gathered here. This is the community that drives
progress in cancer, a community I have been proud
to be part of for the last 28 years.
So thank you for the work that you do, often without immediate reward,
but always with the belief that it will matter.
I'd like to start with something personal.
When I started as a physician scientist, I did basic protein
chemistry in the laboratory, and I took care of blood cancer patients in the
clinic.
I was frustrated by how difficult it was to link the two efforts.
I often thought of it like linking expertise in something like car
maintenance with expertise in ballet.
I remember thinking, as a trainee on the leukemia service, how great
it would be someday to see someone treated based on something I studied in
the laboratory, but I could not see it then.
However, I persisted, truly enjoying both aspects of
my work, until the day arrivedWhen I saw a way forward
to targeting programmed cell death in chronic lymphocytic leukemia,
and later acute myelogenous leukemia and other diseases.
Twenty years after I started as an oncology fellow,
I saw a patient on my leukemia service treated with venetoclax for AML.
There has been no more gratifying moment for me in my career.
Now, of course, I did not do this alone.
I depended on the superb molecular biology performed by many others
before me, including my late mentor, Stan Korsmeyer.
I depended on collaborators with whom I could share ideas and build
confidence, like Marina Konopleva.
There would be no drug to give people without the superb medicinal
chemistry of AbbVie.
And most of all, I depended on the wonderful people who worked with me in my
laboratory.
This experience taught me that to really change things for cancer patients,
you do need a community. You also need resources to
keep the research going for many years, something I think we can overlook
at the end of the road when a successful treatment is approved by the FDA
and becomes a new standard of care.
The point I'm getting to is my work started with a single
NCI grant. In fact, the work that I depended on
depended on NCI grants that stretched back for almost two decades.
I took this job because I knew that the beginning of nearly all cancer
breakthroughs
started with a single NCI grant.
For just a few examples, there are the HPV vaccines that prevent
cervical and other cancers before they ever occur.
These were developed by Dr. Doug Lowy, Aimee Kramer, and John Schiller.
These vaccines came from decades of NCI-supported research.
Cellular immunotherapy, a breakthrough so great it landed Steve Rosenberg on the
cover of Time magazine. That started with an NCI grant.
Checkpoint inhibitors
that revolutionized cancer treatment came from continuous funding from the
NCI for Doctors Jim Allison, Gordon Friedman, and Tasuku
Honjo.
You are sitting in this audience among luminaries.
Their work has had enormous ripple effects throughout the entire research
community.
Over the next few days, you'll see work at every stage.
Some of it will be early, focused on mechanisms, targets, or model
systems. Some will be translational.
Some will include clinical data.
The way NCI tries to move the needle is by funding the best
research at each of these levels. More than three-quarters of the
funding NCI receives from Congress goes directly to
investigators like you and laboratories in the extramural
community across the country. Science has always driven the
NCI, and it continues to drive the NCI.
So I encourage you to apply for NCI funding and apply
again to help drive the next generation of cancer breakthroughs.
Something else I think we need to do at the NCI is connect better to the
American public.
Today, we're launching an initiative we're calling Your NCI to tell the
story to the American taxpayer of just how rich their initial
investment in cancer research is and how it pays off in cancer
prevention, screening, diagnosis, survivorship, and better,
more effective treatments.
Let me share the first of several videos we have planned with the story of
pembrolizumab that started with a single NCI grant and is now
treating patients with more than 40 different cancers.
Can we start that video, please? What often stands between a patient and a
cure is not the lack of excellent doctors or hospitals.
It is the lack of enough truly effective treatments.
One of the core missions of the National Cancer Institute, part of the
National Institutes of Health, is to change that.
This is the story of the development of checkpoint inhibitors, a new class
of treatments that has revolutionized cancer care, made possible
by NCI.
In the 1990s, researcher Dr. James Allison and others,
supported directly by NCI grants, ran experiments showing that
a protein, CTLA-4, acts as a brake on the immune
system.
When they blocked that brake in lab experiments, they found that the immune system
attacked and cleared tumors.
Around the same time, with support from NCI, Dr.
Tasuku Honjo and colleagues began studying another protein on immune
cells called PD-1.
Together, their work laid the foundation for an entirely new class
of cancer therapy built on years of NCI-supported
foundational and translational research.
Their discoveries earned them the Nobel Prize in 2018.
In 2011, a new drug called pembrolizumab was the
first to be given to patients with advanced melanoma.
At the University of California, Los Angeles, NCI-supported clinical
investigators, including Dr. Anthony Ribas, saw
something remarkable. In some patients, tumors shrank
dramatically. In others, they went away completely.
Those clinical trial findings helped lead to rapid FDA approval in
2014, but NCI's investment did not stop there.
Supported by an NCI Cancer Center Support grant, researchers at Johns
Hopkins led a landmark trial proving that checkpoint inhibitors work
across cancers that share a specific genetic characteristic known as
dMMR. In May 2017, for the
first time ever, a cancer drug was approved based on a tumor's
genetic biomarker, not the organ it came from.
Alongside NCI-supported research, partners across academia,
foundations, and the biotech and pharmaceutical industries helped bring
these discoveries to patients.
And it was stage IIIB non-small
cell carcinoma
And they had me, starting out,
they were going to do radiation and chemotherapy at the same time,
which didn't go very well.
I want to say I was on the pembro maybe six months.
Because you're kind of every day you're like, "Is this working? Is this working?
Is it working?" Then all of a sudden it's gone.
It's a great relief.
Pembrolizumab is now approved for more than 43 cancer
settings.
Stories like this are possible because of decades of research supported by
NCI.
Today, NCI continues to drive progress with a
$14.5 million program project grant, funding
five active clinical trials to make immunotherapy work for
cancers that do not yet respond.
I think behind every treatment breakthrough, there is a
long history of support for research from the
NCI, and that has led to so many different
breakthroughs in cancer therapies across the years.
The story of checkpoint inhibitors is often told as a single cancer
breakthrough. But from the beginning, behind that single
breakthrough was a single great idea and a single
NCI grant.
It's a testament to the long arc of cancer research supported by NCI,
support that carries on, reducing the suffering of cancer to this
day.
I'd like to leave you with three ways you might approach this meeting.
Listen for the early ideas. All the great ideas started as early
ideas.
Engage with people outside your usual circle.
That's one of the great things about this meeting.
And finally, think about how to translate your ideas to help cancer
patients. Keep a line of sight to translation,
even if it is a very long line.
I look forward to seeing you in the scientific sessions over the next few days.
Please stop by the NCI exhibit booth to share ideas and connect.
Enjoy the meeting, and get inspired. Thank you.
Thank you so much, Dr. Lattai, for your time and your wisdom.
So now it's my honor to introduce a leader to whom
this community owes a profound debt of gratitude.
A leader who at a moment when the future of medical research hung in the
balance, stood up, spoke out,
and made certain that life-saving science would continue reaching the
patients who need it the most. Senator Susan
Collins of Maine has served in the United States
Senate for decades, for nearly three decades.
As chair of the Senate Appropriations Committee, the first Republican
woman to hold that position, she has been a tireless and
unwavering champion of medical research funding,
and you know how much we all appreciate that.
Her commitment to medical research was never more consequential
than last year.
When the administration proposed slashing NIH funding by $20
billion, she stood up as one of the most powerful Republicans in
Washington and made clear that this was not a partisan
issue. She dedicated the very first hearing of her
tenure as chair to examining what those cuts would mean
for patients, scientists, and the future of American
innovation and public health.
In her opening statement, she said it plainly, "There is no investment that
pays greater dividends to American families than our investment in this
research,
which can lead to life-saving and life-enhancing discoveries."
Because of her leadership, Congress rejected those cuts and secured
a $415 million increase for NIH
instead, as you know. In addition to her extraordinary
support for funding cancer research, Senator Collins has
led efforts to provide cancer screenings to more than six million
women nationwide. She's championed vital pediatric
cancer legislation and really also ensured the
expansion of demographic
representation in federally funded clinical trials.
We are deeply grateful to her for her leadership, and we are
proud to present her with AACR's 2026
Distinguished Public Service Award.
Unfortunately, Senator Collins is unable to join us in
person, but she has shared with us an important video message.
Good morning.
I am so grateful for this recognition, and
I'm honored to join AACR
in your mission to prevent and cure cancer
through research, education, and
advocacy. Let me begin by
applauding the scientists, healthcare
professionals, survivors, patients, family
members, and advocates for your
dedication to this cause.
There is hardly a family in America
that has not been touched by cancer.
There is no investment we can make that
provides greater returns for Americans
than our investment in biomedical research.
It's not an exaggeration to say that this
research changes lives and can
even change the world.
I'm proud that we, on the Senate Appropriations
Committee, have worked together to increase
funding for the National Institutes of Health,
including the National Cancer
Institute.The United States leads
the world in biomedical innovation
and research. That's why patients come from
all over the globe to be treated in
our medical centers and to participate
in our cutting-edge clinical trials.
The importance of maintaining America's
lead in biomedical research is
why last year, as the new chair of the Senate
Appropriations Committee, the very first
hearing that I held was on biomedical
research, keeping America's edge in
innovation. I then led a
bipartisan coalition to secure a
$415 million increase
for the NIH, rejecting the
administration's misguided proposal
for a 41% cut in
the NIH's budget.
Studies have concluded that NIH-funded
basic science has contributed to the
development of more than 90% of
new medicines, vaccines, and medical
devices.
These new drugs, vaccines, and devices
have saved or improved countless lives.
They've also given hope to many
American families. For example,
NIH funding supported advances in
CT scans, enabling earlier
detection of lung cancer, a
breakthrough that "Stat News" ranked as
one of the top medical advances of
2025.
It is essential that we maintain a
steady, predictable stream of federal
research funding. In the past, Congress
provided ample money in some years, then
retrenched in others, or provided only
short-term funding extensions.
These actions by Congress created needless
uncertainty for our researchers.
I'm committed to establishing stable
funding pathways so that researchers,
scientists, and physicians can be confident
that their important work will continue to
have consistent support.
I'm encouraged that Congress has worked in a
bipartisan manner to provide
transformative research funding that will bring
tangible hope to so many
Americans.
None of this would've happened without all of
you here today. You are making
a difference, and I am so happy
to join you in this effort. Thank you for all
you do. Keep up your great work. It is
truly transforming lives.
Well, it doesn't get any better than that, I would say.
Thank you to Senator Collins for your inspiring words of support
and for your exceptional commitment to prioritizing life-saving
cancer research and medical science.
Senator Collins and a super majority of her colleagues in Congress
truly recognize that for decades, the NIH and
NCI have served as the nation's foundation for medical research and
cancer science and medicine, supporting basic research
discoveries that have led to groundbreaking treatments,
increased survival rates, and enhanced quality of life for
patients. This support of NIH and
NCI has been vitally important to progress, but during the
past year, we witnessed unprecedented disruptions and
restrictions from the current administration on NIH and NCI
efforts, including the President's damaging budget
proposals for fiscal years 2026 and
2027 to slash funding for life-saving medical
research. The remarkable support that we witnessed
firsthand from our leaders on Capitol Hill during the past year, most
especially Senators Collins, Patty Murray,
Shelley Moore Capito, and Tammy
Baldwin, as well as Representatives Tom Cole,
Rosa DeLauro, and Robert Aderholt, was simply
extraordinary.
Working with their colleagues in Congress, they stood up in unified
opposition to the President's FY26 budget request
for the NIH and asserted their
responsibility by instead providing NIH with a
robust funding increase in this fiscal year.
By taking this action, Congress has shown its commitment to protecting the
progress already achieved against human diseases, including
cancer, and to accelerating further discoveries that will
benefit patients and their families in the years to come.
In response to these courageous efforts from our leaders on Capitol Hill,
a letter from nearly 200 fellows of the AACR
Academy, a distinguished group of AACR presidents,
Nobel laureates, and preeminent leaders in cancer research, was
shared earlier this year with these leaders and their colleagues on
Capitol Hill.We want you to know that in this letter, the
fellows expressed their heartfelt appreciation for the
extraordinary efforts of members of Congress to finalize the
fiscal year 2026 Labor, H& Human
Services, Education, and Related Agencies appropriations
process and prioritize funding for
NIH and NCI. Therefore, to
continue to express our gratitude to members of Congress, we want
to conclude this amazing opening ceremony by showing our
appreciation to them for rejecting the president's initial budget
proposal for the current fiscal year, which would have cut
funding by NIH and NCI by 40%.
In its wisdom, Congress united around the message that NIH
funding must be increased, not cut,
and that medical research and public health must remain a
national priority. And now I ask you to please stand to raise
the placards on your seat so that our cameras can capture this
display of appreciation for our policymakers' ongoing
dedication to support medical research for the health and
benefit
of all.
How spectacular is that?
Thank you. You're good.
You're good, Todd.
Thank you.
We did this last year, and
it was extremely successful in our advocacy, and I appreciate
very much your doing this again. This is going to go far in our ability
to make our case and inspire hope for
all. So in addition to sharing this moment widely on social media
and other channels, we will be sending photos of today's event to
all 535 members of Congress and their staffs as
we encourage them to continue their commitment to NIH and NCI
during fiscal year 2027 appropriations process.
In the end-- Oh, thank you. Thank you.
We're working hard, and I know that you know that our purpose is
clear, our mission is urgent, and our commitment is
unwavering. We cannot allow our life-saving mission to be
adversely affected by the administration's plan to cut NIH funding by
20% for
FY27. Over the next several days, you will hear about
extraordinary scientific breakthroughs, and you will be presenting them
yourselves. The discoveries presented at this meeting will travel far and
wide beyond these halls,
and they will move us ever closer to a future in which
cancer is prevented, detected early, and cured.
This is the enduring impact of the AACR Annual Meeting.
So thank you for your brilliance and your ceaseless commitment to the mission
we chair.
The future is bright, and it is you who will light the path
forward to more progress against cancer.
And now please welcome again to the stage our president, Dr. C.